- Earlier we saw a picture of your son.
So here you are as a
kid, which is adorable.
(laughing)
And now you remind me of my son.
- [Adam] Uh huh.
- Is it a boy thing?
Because here's the thing,
my son will full on look
you right in the face
while talking and getting something.
- Oh yeah.
- I'm like, you know, I'm sitting here
and I can see you picking your booger.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- It's awesome.
- [Kelly] It's a boy thing, I think.
- I think you're right.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I mean, I think that
- I Think girls, we're shady
but we'll hide about it.
We're hiding.
- Yeah. You still do it.
- They're hidden, my daughter I'll catch.
- You have the decency not to
do that when the camera comes.
Right?
(laughing)
- This is awesome though.
- Yeah, I think I thought
I was being hilarious
and not knowing that one
day it would be broadcast
on the Kelly Clarkson Show.
- You're welcome.
You're welcome.
That's what we're here for.
- Thank you, very much.
- [Kelly] Just to make
you, just bring it down.
(laughing)
- Appreciate it.
- So wait, what's something
that your parents let you do
that you'd never let your kids do?
- Oh, you know, they used to
I got really into
grateful dead for a while.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I don't know if you ever
got into grateful dead.
When I was a teenager
- I know the type of people
that were in into grateful dead.
(laughing)
- And that was me, for two years.
And they used to, I don't think they were
aware exactly what the
grateful dead entailed,
but they would drive me
to grateful dead concerts.
They let me take a bus up to San Francisco
with a friend to go to
a grateful dead show
and spend the night in San.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I mean, this was like a while ago.
This would never happen now, right?
- I would never let my kids. Yeah, No.
- Never. I remember my
dad drove us up to a venue
and he's like, okay guys,
me and a friend of mine,
and as soon as he pulled
up, the people like
surrounded the car and was
offering to sell him shrooms.
- And he still was like,
go have a good time, son
- Like yeah, have fun.
What, what is this?
(laughing)
It's the grateful dead.
It's not a big deal.
- It is funny.
My parents went like, I never was home.
I was on my bike until
like, the sun went down.
I had to be home.
- [Adam] Same.
- They never knew where I
was. I would never let my kids
- You leave in the morning
and you're gone all day.
- But what, maybe the problem is us
because I feel like they did alright.
I'm alright.
- Yeah
- I mean, I am in
therapy, but I am alright.
But like, I feel like
everyone should be in therapy
by the way, but
- Whether you left home all day or not.
- Whether you need it at
that specific moment or not.
(audience clapping)
But, my point is
that maybe we should
give them more freedom.
I don't know.
Cause I had so much
freedom just like that.
- Yeah, me too. Me too.
I mean, I think if we
did, they would be fine.
- [Kelly] I know.
- But it's still hard.
- What's wrong with us? Control freaks.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Apparently. I don't know.
I think we just learned
something together, Adam.
- [Adam] I think you're right.
Um so anyway (laughs) I
probably won't change though.
They're not going out there.
(laughing)
- No way. No way.
- So wait in parks rec you
got to meet Joe Biden, right?
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Cause I got to meet him. He was so nice.
- The coolest.
- [Kelly] So what was
your experience like?
- It was great. He came on, he
was, had a role on the show.
Like he was obviously
playing himself, but yeah
he was so good and such a pro
like really good on camera,
knew his lines.
And then we did another episode
where he and Dr. Biden were
both on, the first lady we're both on,
and they were the best. They're so nice.
- [Kelly] Yeah. They're very sweet.
- Yeah.
- Like behind the scenes,
that's what I thought
was the coolest, like she
was asking me about like,
just life, like kids, like normal stuff.
And I was like, oh, okay.
You're like being normal. Okay.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- And not that you're not
normal, but you know what I mean.
- And he's like, Adam how are you?
And like, he'll like shake
your hand and you're like,
oh okay. There's like this
magic thing here where
you're making me feel like
I'm the most important
person in the world.
- I know. I know.
And then you like start divulging stuff.
- Yeah.
- Actually, you're like yeah.
(laughing)
Can I tell you about
something that happened
to me when I was a little
kid? Yeah, Yeah, Yeah.
- [Kelly] My childhood, yes.
- No, I'm not actually into that.
- [Kelly] My mom, let me go
see the grateful dead and
- [Adam] That's right. That's right.
(laughing)
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you Kelly. Thanks everybody.
- I love you, like on
screen, but I love you
even more in person.
- Likewise.